hallo herzlich willkommen in SIS Welt
ich bin gerade hier in FL bei nobelia
auf der Hausmesse und wir haben richtig
volles Programm eigentlich sollte ich
jetzt Herzen kaiserschman Backen so wie
es bei mir in der App steht mit Spinat
mit champag Jungs aber die Zutaten sind
gerade nicht da also habe ich mir
gedacht ich habe eh gerade Lust auf
süßen Kaiserschmarn und jetzt gibt's
haltet euch fest Kaiserschmarn nach
morkuchenart mit Früchten oh mein Gott
das wird ein geniales Rezept denn ich
habe noch nie auf der Welt muchen
kaiserschmann gesehen ich zeig euch mal
die Zutaten dafür verwende ich se Eiweiß
eine Prise Salz 30 g Zucker se Eigelb
Vanilleextrakt ihr könnt aber auch Tonka
nehmen 250 g Mehl Backpulver brauche ich
jetzt hier nicht 500 ml Milch für die
schokoversion noch 30 g Kakao 50 g Milch
oder Amaretto oder etwas rum etwas
Butter zum Schmelzen und Zitronenschalen
abreben ich habe mir das einfach gerade
ausgedacht weil ich dachte
schokokiserschmann habe ich schon
vanillekaiserschmann habe ich schon es
gibt auch schon in vielen Versionen aber
mamakuchen hat noch keiner gemacht okay
ihr nehmt jetzt einfach Eiweiß schlagt
das ganze mit salzsteif lasst den Zucker
einreseln und dann nur noch so etwa
halbsteif ver rühren nicht so lange
trocken
[Musik]
rühren und in der Zwischenzeit einfach
schon mal die Butter schmelzen aber
aufpassen dass sie nicht zu heiß
wird
[Musik]
perfekt den Eischnee stelle ich kurz zur
Seite neben eine zweite Schlüssel und da
könnt ihr nämlich Eigel mit
Vanilleextrakt und Zitronenabrieb
berühren einfach so ein bisschen cremig
so den echten mamakuchen gehört ein
bisschen Zitronenabrieb nicht zu viel
und eigentlich auch im Schuss Rum dann
hat man so den perfekten
[Musik]
Geschmack sehr rot sieht es aus jetzt
nehme ich den Schneebesen raus den Rest
machen wir nämlich ohne Maschine jetzt
kann ich hier abwechseln so ein bisschen
Mehl dazu geben dann Milch dann Eischnee
unterheben und natürlich die Butter
einrühren und so entsteht jetzt erstmal
der helle
[Musik]
Teig
so jetzt ist der Teig erstmal flüssig da
hebe ich jetzt gleich den Eischnee unter
aber was ihr auch schon mal vorbereiten
könnt ist Kakao und Milch verrühren
damit sich das schon mal
[Musik]
verbindet jetzt nehmen wir die
Hälfte verühen erstmal ein bisschen was
mit der Schokoladenmasse wichtig ist
nämlich den kaiserschmteig nicht zu
lange rühren sondern eher unterheben
deswegen erstmal die kleine Menge dann
verbindet sich der Kakao gut und dann
könnt ihr die Hälfte der Masse mit Kakao
verrühren jetzt noch mal ein bisschen
drauf dass es so ungefähr halb halb
ist muss nicht ganz aber so ungefähr im
gleichen
Verhältnis
dann habe ich jetzt nämlich hier wie bei
mamakuchen auch einen hellen Teig und
einen dunklen Teig und es wandert jetzt
in die Pfanne statt in eine Backform ich
bin jetzt selber
gespannt jetzt fettet ihr einfach
erstmal eure beschichtete Pfanne und
füllt abwechselnd bischen hellen und
dunklen Teig ein und wir morieren das
dann gleich mit einer Gabel einfach ja
das wird
[Musik]
schon
und jetzt erstmal festbacken lassen von
einer Seite dann wird er erst
gewendet bin mal
gespannt der kaiserschmann backt jetzt
gerade noch aber ich habe schon mal eine
zweite Pfanne aufgestellt eine
Gusseisenpfanne denn kaiserschman
zeichnet sicher dadurch aus dass er
angebraten wird und so eine schöne
Kruste hat die Kruste kommt dadurch
zustande dass sie dann der
Gusseisenpfanne nhmt butter und Zucker
und das macht einfach schon den gesamten
Geschmack damit noch bisschen Crunch
dazu kommt NHM ich Mandeln das heißt ich
habe jetzt hier butter Zucker und
Mandeln die werden jetzt kurz ein
bisschen
gehackt und dann kann ich auch schon mal
die Butter in die Pfanne geben auf die
andere Seite den Zucker und
karamellisieren lassen und zur Butter
gebe ich dann die Mandeln die werden
dann auch schön richtig
braun hier auf die Seite
Zucker
jetzt die Mandeln so ein bisschen rösten
den Zucker nicht verbrennen lassen und
dann auch gerne alles miteinander
kombinieren perfekt guck mal den kann
man jetzt schon wenden der sieht schon
eine halbe Minute lasse ich noch aber
dann wende ich ihn eigentlich ist auch
besser ihr nehmt die Menge die reicht
genau für zwei Pfannen und wenn ihr zwei
Pfannen nehmt dann habt ihr auch nicht
so eine lange Backzeit dann backt ihr
hier den einen da den anderen könnt den
schön wenden und dann wird er geruppt in
die Pfanne ja habe ich natürlich nicht
mehr dran gedacht deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier noch ein minipfännchen aber
das kriegen wir jetzt hier alles hin
hier einfach mal so ein Silikondeckel
drauf zum Backen das wird schon jetzt
versuche ich den jetzt einfach mal zu
wenden
ne ja ich lass i noch ganz
kurz sicher ist sicher ich habe mein
tortenretter vergessen mit tortenretter
könnt ihr den perfekt
umdrehen ich guck mal vielleicht habe
was anderes ne ne egal ich fer einfach
mal den
bratdeckel
geht
doch kurz fertig backen und darin wird
dann gezupft und schön
angebaten ja sobald der kaiserschman
gebacken ist ich teste das einfach mit
kuchentester wenn nichts mehr dran hängt
dann hier rüber geben auf keinen Fall
mit der Gabel in der beschichteten
Pfanne zupfen gehen wir jetzt hier rein
und dann schön auseinanderzupfen und
hier drin Backen das heißt hier kann ich
den Herd jetzt ein bisschen höher
[Musik]
stellen hier noch
direkt alle zum
Probieren also dann darfst du probieren
gerne er sieht hervorragend aus es
riecht hervorragend und wenn es jetzt
auch noch so schmeckt wie es aussieht
und
riecht und ein Traum ja ein Traum
fantastisch Mama Kuchen kaiserschman mit
Früchten heute ausgedacht heute
ausgedacht fantastisch ganz ganz lecker
kann ich nur empfehlen ach sehr schön
ganz aufessen das ist vollkommen für
dich ich ma auch gerne noch eine zweite
Portion alles klar danke perfekt danke
schön Lars das Rezept findet ihr wie
immer in meiner App oder auf
sellisblog.de ich freue mich richtig
dass der kaiserschmann gut angekommen
ist gerne auch die Glocke aktivieren den
Kanal abonnieren und falls ihr es
vergessen habt ich renne jetzt gleich
zur Glocke bitte jetzt Glocke
aktivieren die spontan Rezepte sind halt
immer die besten ach ich freue mich ich
freue
mich hey Leute ich bin Murat und das ist
mein Kumpel günny wir haben
wahrscheinlich momentan die teuerste und
spektakulärste handwerkersendung im
deutschen Fernsehen geht jetzt direkt in
die AD Mediathek gibt dort ein Murat
Dreh amrat und seht uns beim Handwerken
wie wir unglaubliche Dinge machen zeig
do auch was
f die Worte ja mir
auch ich weiß wo das größte Problem
nachher liegen wird das Ding nach in das
Auto
Reinz die wollte das wirklich so dunkel
haben schleib noch mal ab geh
weg
[Musik]
will m
zapie gehen rein einer geht
[Gelächter]
raus aber hast du gar keine Angst dass
die jetzt z.B nicht glücklich sind mit
dem was du auslieferst vielleicht haben
die was anderes erwartet me die Sendung
kann man so zamm schnell das aussieht
dass du was
[Musik]
kannst